on a découvert par exemple Christine qui
habite à Grenoble elle s'est fait
arnaquer sur des sites de rencontres
après un divorce compliqué elle tombe
sur un faux profil et se fait croquer il
se croquer des milliers d'euros regardez
d'une escroquerie cette aide-soignante
c'est lourdement endetté tout a commencé
par un simple message de cet homme sur
un réseau social Christine tombe sous le
charme de ce qu'elle pensait être
l'homme idéal ils échangent tous les
jours des dizaines de messages enflammés
tu es douce tes mains doivent être
douces ils ont de la chance des patients
après quelques mois d'idils virtuel
Dominique lui annonce qu'il a perdu son
emploi il demande à Christine de l'aider
commence alors une longue série de
transferts d'argent Intraçable ce ticket
permet d'effectuer des transactions à
l'étranger en toute discrétion en un an
et demi Christine envoie plus de 10000
euros à Dominique dans l'espoir qu'ils
viennent la rejoindre à Grenoble
alors ça rabbin des bois les arnaques en
ligne alors ça c'est des arnaques
relation des sites ça ça c'est connu
ouais ça c'est assez courant
malheureusement
du Nigéria parce que là-bas en fait
c'est ça a été popularisé c'est ce qu'on
appelle une forme d'ingénierie sociale
on va aller jouer en fait sur les
émotions de la personne sur sa peur
alors ça peut être essayer de faire
tomber quelqu'un amoureux ça peut être
angoissé quelqu'un au point de lui faire
croire qu'il a une amende à payer et les
personnes en fait derrière après sont
démunis ont tendance à payer Gilles moi
j'ai un ami proche à qui c'est arrivé
alors donc c'est vous
et en fait c'est imparable parce que
l'arnaque à la romance elle fonctionne
très bien vous nourrez conversation ça
dure plusieurs mois et au bout d'un
moment la personne donc lui c'était un
garçon c'était une jeune femme qui
devait venir le rejoindre elle lui dit
voilà j'ai besoin de médicaments j'ai un
ennui de santé etc et il a donné
plusieurs milliers d'euros et tous mes
avertissements tombés à l'eau il disait
tu veux casser mon couple et cetera
c'est quand j'ai vu le repasage ça m'a
rappelé cette histoire et c'est
imparable franchement toi avant-hier moi
j'ai reçu un message 06 15 65 31 68
donne le numéro nos agents ont constaté
que votre véhicule n'était pas venu
d'une vignette réglementaire critère
2023 veuillez la récupérer sous peine de
contrevention c'est la cliquez sur le
lien
tu as donné le numéro bah pour que les
gens fassent attention merde
non mais moi comme un con j'ai eu un
doute et il était venu nous voir en 2019
et tu avais dit qu'on répondait pas au
numéro masqué sur aucun lien et depuis
ce jour-là et j'ai eu un doute j'ai mes
cheveux con j'ai une vignette critère
sur ma voiture et j'ai eu un doute
pendant 30 secondes malgré tout moi j'en
reçois quasiment tous les jours que la
vignette critère et au début moi je
m'étais dit on nous dit quand il y a
httpss ça veut dire que c'est tranquille
c'est sécurisé or maintenant y compris
les voleurs utilisent HTTPS donc comment
est-ce que tu peux savoir que le
transfert de données c'est chiffré de
bouton bout donc personne ne peut
intercepter maintenant
un élément malveillant quelqu'un qui
peut vous arnaquer en un acteur peut
très bien monter un site internet
c'est plus sur
qui vous envoie le le message et
qu'est-ce que vous quelque part vous
avez à perdre pourquoi lui ferait ça
faut faire très attention surtout sur
Chronopost là alors on a aussi un aperçu
on a aussi un aperçu de ce qui se passe
de l'autre côté de l'écran chez les
arnaqueurs que l'on appelle brouteur
notamment à Abidjan en Côte d'Ivoire
regardez
les gens en Côte d'Ivoire est le royaume
des escrocs du cœur ces escrocs se sont
baptisés les brouteurs car il broute la
laine sur le dos de leur victime
le scénario est toujours le même rendre
la victime amoureuse installez la
confiance puis au bout de quelques mois
prétextez un graphe problème pour
réclamer de l'argent pour attirer ses
victimes il crée de faux profils de
femmes
souvent les sites de pornographie après
la mise en confiance on peut rentrer
dans une procédure d'argent
truie aussi les mails de personnes qu'on
connaît
exactement j'ai besoin d'argent pour moi
je veux dire la vérité je suis une barre
de fer donc frère plein de fois moi j'ai
eu des gars vraiment des gars proche
ouais je dis nique ta mère voilà
mais c'est vrai que ça ça peut
franchement ça arrive très souvent
encore une fois c'est des gens qui donc
ils se font passer pour quelqu'un que
vous connaissez parce qu'ils ont pu
hacker l'adresse email par exemple après
ils envoient un message en masse à
toutes les personnes qui sont dans la
liste des sacs en disant frérot je suis
dans la merde est-ce que tu prends un
petit billet ou deux à dépanner et toi
bah c'est un frère bien sûr tu as envie
de l'aider mais d'un autre côté toujours
faire preuve de conscience numérique
appelé la personne au téléphone
achat sur internet ce documenter c'est
beaucoup plus simple j'ai bloqué la
personne au téléphone pour ne plus avoir
de nouvelles
[Rires]
pratiquement une fois par semaine moi je
reçois aussi mon Chronopost parce que
j'ai 40 centimes de qu'il faut que je
paye parce que
en fait sur le fait que vous devez payer
des frais internationaux la majeure
partie des gens attendent de temps en
temps des colis mais du point de vue de
l'arnaqueur c'est magique imaginez si
vous envoyez 100000 SMS à 100000
personnes même si tu as 1 % des gens qui
payent ça fait une personne 3 € 50 tu
fais une journée à 35 c'est magnifique
concrètement ça va très vite il faut
faire très attention il y a aussi
énormément de personnes qui sont passées
pour la police qui font des amendes
alors je suis en cyber juge tout ça j'ai
vu si il faut que tu payes attention
encore aussi à ça et beaucoup de gens
qui se font passer pour la banque aussi
on arrive à quelqu'un ici donc on vous
appelle on dit que on dit qu'il y a un
problème sur votre compte on vous
demande d'aller sur l'application de
mettre le code pour valider le paiement
et à ce moment-là c'est foutu il rentre
dans votre système et ils vous prennent
tout votre argent effectivement donc si
la banque vous appelle en fait et vous
rappelez à votre tour la banque en fait
Castaldi
moi j'ai eu un chantage sur des photos
j'ai reçu un mail donc voilà on a accès
à toutes vos photos il faut verser de
l'argent précédent va tout diffuser et
les photos qu'ils avaient qui m'ont
montré c'était vraiment des photos à moi
qui ont été prises sur mon répertoire
vraiment cloud est-ce qu'il faut mettre
des choses d'ailleurs
je déconseillerai ça dépend en fait il
faut une conscience numérique et une
hygiène numérique où vous savez que vos
mots de passe vous la réutilisez pas
partout vous pouvez avoir des clés de
sécurité physique de connexion de façon
à ce que personne ne puisse se connecter
à vous même si l'autre personne trouve
le mot de passe ou l'adresse email ce
qu'il faut vraiment c'est il faut
comprendre en fait que le monde évolue
le crime évolue et que malheureusement
c'est plus rentable de faire de l'argent
derrière un ordinateur que dans la rue
alors on a d'autres arnaques qui sont
passés les amis on retrouve aussi pour
qu'on arnaque sur les sites de location
de maison Pauline s'est fait avoir par
une fausse annonce du site Abritel et
elle a perdu beaucoup d'argent regardez
cette cadre parisienne avait répondu à
une annonce publiée sur le site Abritel
pour une très belle villa à 2500 euros
elle réserve en toute confiance mais une
fois sur place c'est la douche froide on
est arrivé et on a trouvé le
propriétaire à l'intérieur de la maison
qu'on avait loué pour la semaine
propriétaire qui nous a assuré ne jamais
avoir mis la maison en location sur le
site par lequel on était passé et donc
par là très clairement on a compris
qu'on s'était fait arnaquer voilà donc
je vais vous montrer d'autres arnaques
dans un instant parce que le PDG
d'Abritel a d'ailleurs réagi à ces
dernières actes sur le site internet de
sa société c'est complètement dédouané
chose que déplore les clients qui sont
faits en acier regarder
peut faire pour empêcher de nouvelles
escrocs parce que vous en avez
connaissance ce qu'on dit aux personnes
qui viennent réserver des vacances sur
notre site on leur dit de réserver sur
d'autres sites de payer sur notre site
et de communiquer sur notre site ces
victimes ne sont pas passées par Abritel
elles n'ont pas réservé sur notre site
c'est hyper important comme notion le
risque zéro malheureusement de
cybercriminalité sur internet il
n'existe pas
il y a des gens qui essayent de passer
en direct aussi outre le autre passé sur
le site comme ça c'est officiel je sais
pas comment t'expliquer parce qu'en fait
ils veulent communiquer en privé donc du
coup il chopent leur adresse pour pas
communiquer via le site et payer les
frais du site etc donc en fait il se
chope en direct les gens et c'est ça le
problème parce qu'en fait le
propriétaire quand le faux propriétaire
quand tu dis que tu es intéressé par la
maison te dit écoutez moi ce serait plus
simple peut-être je peux je peux même la
faire un petit rabais de 5% parce que
comme ça je mets pas les 5% que je
donnerais à Abritel et
mais donc alors il y a une autre arnaque
aussi un des sites que l'on retrouve le
plus d'arnaque alors regardez bien ça
c'est sur le bon coin on y va tous sur
leboncoin on découvre qu'il y a beaucoup
d'annonces de voitures qui sont en
réalité des arnaques et qu'il est très
facile de se faire piéger regarde
il a économisé pendant des mois pour
s'offrir ce modèle d'occasion repéré sur
un site de vente entre particuliers la
voiture était conforme à l'annonce
165000 km 4300 euros ça me semblait une
bonne affaire carte grise certificat
d'assurance tout semble en règle le
vendeur lui présente aussi l'épreuve
d'un suivi régulier chez un garagiste
mais il va très vite déchanter que il
n'avait pas cette en tête en fait ce
modèle de facture ils n'ont pas c'est
que du faux le contrôle technique qui
est totalement faux cette voiture je
l'ai acheté à 165000 km et réellement
elle en a 312000
c'est un truc de ouf la voiture elle a
fait trois fois
là on peut rien faire heureusement tout
ce qui est contrefaçon ou alors pour les
voitures même les fausses montres
là-dessus sur leboncoin c'est un frérot
il faut faire très attention et bien ce
documenter pour être sûr de pas se faire
il y a beaucoup de contrats sur
leboncoin mais généralement quand
l'affaire elle est trop belle
il y a quelque chose
j'avais vu une jeune fille sur leboncoin
et je suis arrivé sur la même à 1900
contrefaçon je suis un garçon
il existe des sites qui remontent
l'historique des véhicules souvent elle
est renseignez-vous dans les contrôles
techniques souvent elle a déjà fait les
contrôles techniques les factures
appelées les garages sur les factures
le pire c'est qu'il est très rare de
récupérer son argent on le voit bien
dans cette séquence au tribunal ou les
accusés voilà en ont mis strictement
rien à faire mais dessus de ce qui leur
arrive regardez sans battre les yachts
total
des victimes de plus en plus inquiets et
des prévenus qui semble détendu on les
voit tout à fait tranquille ils sont
adossés ils dorment il baille c'est
qu'une formalité les prévenus assurent
qu'ils ont été dupés par un mystérieux
escroc romain qui aurait trafiqué les
voitures et passer les annonces sur
internet avant de leur en confier la
vente
mail moi je me doutais un peu que la
voiture était pas prête mais voilà merci
beaucoup et à la prochaine
à la prochaine
mais après on n'est pas vraiment studio
je suis d'accord alors je voudrais vous
montrer une nouvelle arnaque à la mode
avant que tu dises à nos téléspectateurs
des choses auxquelles il faut faire
attention quand vous recevez des choses
un des mails ou des sms il y a une
nouvelle arnaque à la mode c'est
l'arnaque aux vaches la promesse
d'investir dans les vaches avec un
rendement annoncé entre 6 et 12%
alors que les vaches sont inexistantes
regardez alors ça je connaissais pas
alors c'est la fraude aux vaches
regardez
la dernière escroquerie en vogue un faux
investissement dans les vaches laitières
l'offre est alléchante
1295 € la vache avec des rendements
pouvant aller jusqu'à 12 % des vaches
totalement fictives malgré une
documentation rassurante une entourloupe
qui a conduit des investisseurs crédules
à miser des dizaines de milliers d'euros
derrière ces faux sites internet se
cachent des escrocs très organisés
agissant depuis l'étranger voilà c'est
incroyable ça alors l'arnaque OVA je
connaissais pas Gilles internationaux
effectivement c'est super bien vu parce
que c'est une problématique qui joue sur
la problématique retour à la campagne
Nouveau Monde investissement intéressant
et colo etc et plein de gens sont dupés
et moi ce que je voulais demander à
Romain Desbois c'est ça c'est un
parrainable
c'est on voit ça franchement non mais
frère si tu penses que tu peux avoir une
rentabilité
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu peux nous dire les trois
quatre trucs à savoir pour pas que les
gens se fassent arnaquer
véritablement c'est de la conscience
numérique c'est réalisé s'il y a une
affaire qui est trop belle il faut il
faut se documenter c'est que c'est sans
doute une arnaque petit 1 petit 2
essayez quand même de d'avoir les mêmes
habitudes sur en ligne c'est-à-dire
acheter sur Amazon ou sur la Fnac si
vous pouvez en vrai c'est je sais que
bon voilà le monopole tout ça mais la
réalité de la chose c'est qu'avec Amazon
ou la Fnac tu devrais pas avoir ce genre
de problème et surtout surtout c'est ce
documenter sur ce que vous êtes en train
de faire ne serait-ce que si vous
achetez une trottinette électrique
n'importe quoi ce que vous voulez aller
sur internet tapez le nom du shop
regardez si par exemple il y a déjà des
effets de personnes qui ont dit je me
suis fait arnaquer ou pas documenter et
quand on reçoit des trucs ici il faut
faire alors si tu reçois un sms
et que généralement ça va être quelque
chose où il faut que tu payes ou alors
il y a un problème ou c'est l'état ou
alors c'est la police ça faut surtout
pas répondre il faut comment dire il
faut bien se rendre compte que si un
jour tu as un vrai problème il y a
quelqu'un qui va t'envoyer un recommandé
chez toi tu vas avoir quelque chose
un juge ne va pas te condamner à payer
2000 euros par un sms ou avec un
paiement en ligne c'est il faut un
moment aussi s'armer de conscience
numérique et réaliser que les gens
veulent à votre argent malheureusement
il faut se protéger contre ça c'est quoi
l'arnaque aux fan de célébrités vous
connaissez ça ou pas
sur Instagram c'est-à-dire que tu vas
avoir des célébrités d'Internet où il va
y avoir des comptes qui vont se créer ou
ils vont usurper en fait l'identité de
la célébrité et derrière ils vont aller
liker et s'abonner à tous les gens qui
s'abonnent à la vraie star ils vont lui
dire salut c'est Squeezie c'est
n'importe qui j'ai récupéré j'ai vu que
tu t'étais abonné à moi je peux
t'envoyer un iPhone si tu veux mais ça
c'est ça on peut le dire parce que je
pense que la majorité des chroniqueurs
ici on a eu des faux comptes à nos noms
qui usurpent Nono et qui faisait
soi-disant gagner des iPhone et autres
ils vont aussi voilà il faut le dire il
y a personne ici au téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent personne ne vous
demandera d'argent de des chroniqueurs
de TPMP à part peut-être dans la rue
les personnes ne vous demandera d'argent
sur Internet et ne les pas les concours
soi-disant pour payer un euro pour avoir
un iPhone puis en vaut 1000 2 on verra
pas combien ça n'existe pas donc voilà
il y a aussi l'arnaque au numéro qui
démarre par 09 c'est quoi ça ah ouais
c'est à dire que des numéros qui sont
surprisés parfois on a vu ça pendant le
covid j'ai trouvé ça incroyable il y
avait des gens qui appelaient qui ont
envoyé des sms pour dire vous êtes en
contact appeler ce numéro de téléphone
le numéro de téléphone il est surtaxé
c'est pas toi tu es dans la rassera
d'avoir le covid tu appelles un numéro
et tu perds de l'argent faut éviter en
fait tout ce qui est 09 tous les numéros
comme ça un petit peu bizarre sombre je
vous conseille de même pas décrocher en
fait je crois que j'ai compris aussi
pourquoi personne n'appelait Daniel je
crois que Daniel est un 09
il faut changer son code de téléphone
très souvent ou pas
à vous dire qu'il faut changer le mot de
passe surtout de vos adresses email et
des différents services que vous
utilisez très souvent parce qu'en fait
la plupart des gens malheureusement
utilisent le même mot de passe ce qui
fait que si jamais un de ces services se
fait hacker moi derrière si votre mot de
passe c'est Géraldine de 3 j'ai accès à
tout partout chez vous donc avoir des
mots de passe différents changer souvent
est-ce qu'on peut faire confiance à
l'authentification à deux facteurs ouais
l'authentification
c'est une clé une clé physique ou
directement tu rentres dans l'iPhone ou
sur sur l'ordinateur et ta fille dessus
et c'est une authentification à deux
facteurs c'est ce que tous les
professionnels de cybercitif
c'est comme une petite clé USB que tu
vois donc
à chaque fois que je veux faire mon code
il faut que je rentre un truc des types
des irmans ou ce genre de choses c'est
pour les opérations
des arnaques qui vient de l'étranger
comme les vaches ou comme les mecs sur
les sites de rencontres on peut remonter
jusqu'à où ils sont Intraçable on les
retrouvera jamais c'est difficile à
manger tendance à penser malheureusement
que une fois que le mal est fait c'est
très compliqué de revoir son argent j'ai
envie de dire que faut se rapprocher des
services de police compétents mais
objectivement si déjà ça a été fait par
la par la forme de crypto monnaie votre
argent vous avez beaucoup de chance de
pas revoir et
malheureusement je pense qu'il y a des
assurances qui sont qui sont on peut
faire jouer dans ce cas de figure bon
après les assurances est-ce qu'elles
veulent rembourser c'est une autre chose
mais c'est très compliqué objects numéro
masqué on continue de répondre où on
répond toujours pas un numéro masqué
c'est souvent la Compagnie Créole
on répond pas
c'est qu'il a quelque chose à se
reprocher ça c'est votre propre choix
quoi après c'est ça qui nous avait dit
ça en 2019
ma carte sim elle est même pas mon nom
en fait moi je veux rien qu'il soit à
moi parce que c'est une façon de se
cavale de se mettre
il faut dire aux gens quand même même
s'il y a pas toujours de remboursement
joli si vous nous regardez à 20h30 en
direct là c'est important et aussi
également de l'arnaque au coiffeur
vraiment faites très attention à ça ils
sont en train de se dire un peu partout
oui toujours porter plainte parce que
porter plainte même si les enquêteurs
français par rapport à l'étranger ils
peuvent pas aller au bout de la piste au
moins porter plainte par rapport à
l'assurance par rapport aux banques
c'est la condition sinequanone donc si
vous êtes victime d'une arnaque allez
porter plainte police ou gendarmerie on
est obligé de prendre votre plainte
toujours